hi my name is Sanjay jayakumar my name
is dr. da Crispo
I'm deaf Eric and I'm Marc Womack and we
were gone and I'm gonna show you how to
find things on Android Market Android
Market has several options for browsing
content that you can download we have
the featured gallery up here at the top
which shows icons of applications that
you can install and we also have
categories of applications and games
going into the applications it shows you
different subcategories or you can look
at all the applications and from here
you can look at you can browse by
popularity of what's popular to really
not so popular and also by date to see
what's the latest things that have been
uploaded and I'm gonna show you how to
search and install an application
through the Android Market
I'd like to install an application that
tracks my carbon footprint on a daily
basis so I can click on the search
button in our Android Market enter the
search query carbon and mark it shows me
all the applications that have carbon in
their description I can then click on
this application called a courier I can
view the details for the application and
once I'm suitably pleased I can install
the application market now shows me the
permissions that are required for this
application some of the permissions that
are required or a network communication
and knowing my location once I've
approved these permissions I can click
on OK and market starts the download and
install in the background I can now go
back to market home browse to any other
application that I'd like I like this
game called Banzai blast and I can start
the install of this simultaneously now
what market is doing is downloading and
installing both applications in the
background once the download and
installation succeeds I receive a
notification on the notification bar I
can pull the notification window and
click on a courier which has been just
installed next I'm going to show you how
you can find all the applications you
have downloaded and write one of them so
I can go and
click on my downloads and I get the list
of all application cluding the two that
we just unloaded so after I'm in this
screen I can go to a choreo and now I
can read about the application again but
I can also write the application so can
click and read it and here we have a
screen where I can give it a score of
between one to five stars so let's give
a four stars above average I could also
post a comment telling people more about
this application if I have more serious
concerns about application I can go and
flag the application and I can and I can
write what is the my concern in this
case there is no there are no concerns
so we'll go back finally here's how to
uninstall an application first I go to
my downloads and I click on Android says
then I press uninstall will tell me that
I'm about to uninstall this application
for my phone and I click ok and then I
can give a reason for why I uninstalled
it if it's malicious I can report it
here
but this is just a game I don't want to
play so I'll choose it